I have news for you unfortunately the
news is that we are going to not have
news about how if at all Donald Trump is
going to resolve these insane conflicts
of interests that have cropped up
between Donald Trump the president are
soon to be President and Donald Trump
the businessman business interests
versus the interests of the United
States we talked about this conversation
with the argentinian president where he
allegedly talked about a 35-story office
building project in my birth city of
Buenos Aires which was stalled for years
he denied talking about that but three
days later supposedly that project was
moving again we've talked about Trump
meeting with his business partners from
India to discuss both diplomacy and
deals we talked about this meeting with
dozens and dozens of diplomats at
Trump's new Washington DC hotel and how
that was such a clear conflict of
interest with the people from around the
world that would be coming to visit
Trump on state business who then would
be staying at Trump's hotel Donald Trump
teased that two days from now on
December 15th he was going to be giving
a press conference where he would
explain how he's going to avoid these
conflicts of interest we anticipated
that it would be laughable but what we
did not necessarily anticipate is that
he wasn't going to do the press
conference at all he has now postponed
it it's not happening his transition
team announced yesterday that the press
conference is getting rescheduled to
next month instead Donald Trump has
tweeted what his plans are the new of a
seemingly pseudo official communication
method for the incoming White House
Trump saying even though I am NOT
mandated by law to do so I will be
leaving my businesses before January
20th so that I can focus full-time on
the presidency two of my children Don
and Eric Plus executives will manage
them no new deals will be done during my
terms in office I will hold a press
conference in the near future to discuss
the business cabinet picks and all other
topics of interest busy times this is a
very weird announcement first of all no
new deals he's going to put his kids in
charge of businesses that aren't going
to be doing any new business while Trump
is president
that's really odd but most importantly
no indication of Trump giving up his
ownership in these businesses which is
really the way to prevent a clear
conflict of interest for presidential
decisions even if you're not running the
business Pat and even without doing new
deals Trump knows what the businesses
are and he knows what types of
presidential decisions might positively
or negatively impact those businesses
yeah that's the thing even when this
press conference was announced weeks ago
we had suspicions that he would still
had bested interest in his company and
we're increasingly realizing that Trump
doesn't seem to know what it means to
have business interests and I'm gonna
give you one hilarious example relating
to Trump's business interest in that
reality show that he's known for The
Apprentice here's how Trump denied
having anything to do with The
Apprentice this is a tweet from three
days ago and this is just absolutely
hilarious quote I have nothing to do
with The Apprentice except for the fact
that I conceived it with Mark Burnett
and have a big stake in it will devote
zero time this is like when Ben Carson
was asked during a debate about his
connection with this bogus supplement
company and ben Carson said it's total
propaganda I have nothing to do with
this business whatsoever I mean yes I
was a paid spokesperson for them and I
gave some Pete some speeches where I
talked about the products being great
and they are great and I take them and I
stand behind the products completely but
I have nothing whatsoever to do with the
company at all it's the same thing that
Trump is tweeting yeah I mean him
staying on as executive producer of the
Celebrity Apprentice is just clear-cut
conflict of interest because NBC the
network that runs that show also has a
news division of course he's going to
give them preferential treatment which I
think maybe though Trump has been
slamming along with most news I mean the
guy's all over the map the point is he
doesn't even seem to get what it means
to have a business interest and a
potential conflict also noticeably
missing from the tweets about how Trump
is going to turn over his businesses to
Eric and Don Jr is any mention of
Trump's oldest daughter Ivanka Trump who
is legally forbidden from being an
official part of Trump's administration
because of these and
nepotism laws she's very quickly moving
in the direction of actually being
involved in the Trump administration
they're trying to figure out how Ivanka
and her husband Trump's son-in-law Jared
Kushner could be involved in some way
that wouldn't violate those
anti-nepotism laws and my sense Pat is
that it's going to be some kind of on
paper informal role that won't violate
the letter of that law but will
obviously completely violate the spirit
of it yeah and Ivanka Trump has already
played a big role in the transition team
by meeting with the leader of Japan and
then meeting with Al Gore to discuss
climate change she's highly highly
involved and Trump just doesn't
understand anything or the other
possibility is he's brilliantly playing
dumb on this until it's too late
you can deflect delay and postpone until
people lose interest maybe because of
some new shiny object that rolls by to
look at and it becomes too late to do
anything about it
none of this this is the main takeaway
none of this is going to be good for the
average American that is the primary
point today's program is made possible
in part by frame bridge I just got my
custom framed picture of my city of
birth boy no situs Argentina I uploaded
the picture to frame bridge I selected
matting I selected a frame I probably
should have taken advantage of the free
help from the expert team at frame
bridge that will advise you on what
matting and framing to pick because I'm
creatively clueless but I think merely
through luck and the alignment of the
universe if you believe in that type of
thing I actually put together something
that's pretty cool and it was delivered
to me just days later framed and ready
to be put up on the wall with mounting
hardware so instead of paying hundreds
of bucks at a framing store frame bridge
prices start at just $39 and the great
thing is shipping is free as you can
imagine shipping framed artwork around
could get expensive but it is included
in the price at frame bridge my viewers
and listeners can get a special discount
if you go to frame bridge calm and use
promo code Pakman PA KMA n you will get
an extra 15% off of your first order
that's frame bridge comm
Packman PA que ma n say 15% get whatever
you want framed
if you can't upload your picture you can
actually send in your artwork to frame
bridge and they will frame it for you
check it out